another video i want to show you gabe
that everyone's been circulating around
you know lee mcgowan politics girl she
has a podcast on minus touch uh we're
proud partners of of midas touch um she
did a video
and uh i wanna
gonna be on i i'm hoping i'm hoping i'm
hoping um that we can get leon to do
commentary uh so folks out there that
are lee mcgowan politics girl fans uh
let her know that do you want to hear
her
her live commentary
uh for the public hearings uh for the
select january 6 select committee um
coming up in the next month so um
definitely give her a shout out there to
say that you want to hear her commentary
but here is a little bit of her
commentary on the current issues stop
saying the democrats are just gonna lose
you know the entire world said the
ukrainians were just gonna lose but it
was inevitable that russia was just too
strong too big too powerful well that
was [ __ ] the ukrainians cared more
they fought back they were told to
surrender and they said hey russian
worship go [ __ ] yourselves and that is
what those of us who love democracy have
to say that's the energy we have to
embrace hey republican party go [ __ ]
yourselves you think you can cheat and
steal and lie and win you think you
could just take our rights from us and
our vote from us and our freedoms from
us and we're just gonna let you i don't
think so yeah i wish the democrats could
get their [ __ ] together and put together
a messaging platform that makes sense
that speaks to the moment but if they
can't we're just going to have to do it
without them just like the brave
ukrainian citizens fought back from
their own windows and made their own
volatile cocktails and acted like the
[ __ ] ballers that they were
democratic voters are not just going to
give up because everyone says we're
going to lose i'm fighting for democracy
for my own goddamn kitchen and i know
i'm not alone this country is filled
with patriots who won't just give up
democracy without a fight we are not
going to lose
we can't lose we have to come out in
droves and convince our people to come
out in force to vote against this sad
pathetic backwards racist homophobic
xenophobic misogynistic [ __ ] party
banning books and gays and women's
rights this anti-democratic party
without values or morals who wants to
take your social security and your
medicare and to fund our public schools
and raise taxes on the poor how can
people even consider voting for them
what are they even offering
we have to decimate this party and then
we have to start the hard work of
building up a country we can all be
proud of one that works for everyone
which is exactly what they are fighting
so hard to avoid but this change only
happens with the democrats the one party
who still believes in democracy i think
the republican party is bitten off more
than they can chew just like the
russians i think they've overplayed
their hand they think they're
untouchable but even with all their
cheating and lying and gerrymandering we
have to show them that they will never
defeat the idea of a free america with
liberty and justice for all hey russian
warship
go [ __ ] yourselves
[Laughter]
oh my god
she always has a way of packing like
10 hours worth of content here every
single week and i feel like that we try
to convey this message every single week
and she has a way of packing it into two
minutes
oh thank you lee for fighting for
democracy from your kitchen from your
microphone now i've been giving people
the messaging so subscribe to
politicsgirl go follow lee everywhere
you can um and listen her breakfast rant
videos are are fantastic as far as
messaging is concerned um gabe this is
this is an important and important time
yeah
and not just like to start this process
today but like tomorrow
next week next month we can't afford to
start this process and that is why
it is so important for people to yell
and scream in the streets even if it
means holding a bullhorn
in front of brett kavanaugh's house
it is time to do that